well the podcast Vil the church' what's
happened now is brought to you by Fuji
sports.com if you're looking for a geese
chin [ __ ] straps a mat a [ __ ] belt
a mouthpiece and anything I'm in a
related if you want quality it starts
with Fuji Sports I'm a fat [ __ ] I'm
always in somebody's clothes guard
they're pulling that tugging on my
sleeve on my neck
they can't rip it down listen tough
durable and quality and the price is in
your [ __ ] range prices started
[ __ ] like 69 bucks I get you're a
purple gay that rocks that's light $4.99
$98 and then all the way up to 130 for
the super ATO which is a light type
competition gay they got the psycho
that's see I go they got the super-ego
they got the basic and then they got the
loo competition you think at the element
listen if you're looking for a gig shin
pad Fuji they but the Fuji
they are [ __ ] in Japan they started
the whole [ __ ] program go to Fuji
Sports calm right now press in church
BAM I get the [ __ ] party
started get 10% off get 10% off
delivered to your house number two if
you're looking for supplements you gotta
go with on it whether it's the shroom
text room to export shroom tech immune
the protein powder whatever [ __ ] you're
looking for I got it
eyelets got it gonna holla calm right
now press ENTER CHH
boom and get them [ __ ] percent
off kick this [ __ ] mutely
dead before the [ __ ] podcast started
with all my Sinatra yeah
and how strong he was and like you can't
do protocol like where he's from where
I'm from you can't go up to a guy like
that and like and there's a great scene
in that close range with Christopher
Walken and Sean Penn we're short
Christopher Walken tells Sean Penn as
his father you could come with me a
couple times if you like it you're in
and one day he's sitting with the whole
family the whole five brothers mmm and
Sean Penn walks in with his girlfriend
they're underage they said the [ __ ]
table and the girl goes by the way he
wants end he wants to join you guys
the apartment in the car and he wants to
join you guys and they all broke into
[ __ ] laughter right in his face and
they all got up and walked out of the
room and Christopher Walken says don't
you have a [ __ ] do something I told
the girl to get the [ __ ] out of the room
and he goes don't you ever talk to me
like that that's the protocol I grew up
with right you can't approach a guy you
know like people call you here and say
shitty and like Facebook yet yeah yeah
well you can't go directly to somebody
you have to have a way around the
something so we're just talking about
like Sinatra's mentality at that at that
point the thing I liked about it was you
talking about when that you're talking
about The Tonight Show thing that
Tonight Show thing were Mickey Rickles
Don Rickles yeah just all the store
remember I grew up in North Bergen which
is the people from Hoboken who moved on
up yeah yeah yeah yeah when the I
learned a lot about who I was when the
Sinatra documentary came out on HBO
because it spoke about Sinatra how he
wasn't allowed above Main Street when he
was a kid the Irish would beat you to
[ __ ] up they were oppressed by the Irish
no those Italians moved out and it's
really weird that I grew up with a weird
mentality like I I think about my life
and I think about my mind and why I
think like that when I watch that
tonight sure thing I listen to Sinatra's
voice mm-hmm and it's everybody who at
Hudson County that's there's something
about a Hudson County like the people I
grew up with their parents all had
Sinatra stories yeah but the best part
of that Rickles coming out is that
Rickles cut through all that he just
walked right up you know oh no that's
brilliant
yeah then he delivered the goods yeah
yeah yeah and Sinatra loved it loved it
well Sinatra had a sense of humor that's
what I'm saying my favorite part about
him was that even though he was Frank
Sinatra you know he let Rickles take the
piss out of him they all poked fun out
of them they all poked fun of him and he
laughed because he had so much
confidence in it that he was like it
doesn't matter what you [ __ ] say I'm
Frank's enough
Cosimo avoiding those excuses for ya got
two bullets for the head like you could
get shot for saying something yeah
somebody in public he'd get shot like
why are you saying this to me those guys
did it he didn't we're talking about the
Elvis doc data memory and then how
Sinatra really liked that story about on
Sunset when he went into the restaurant
what he thought he was eating than a
restaurant hmm and the busboy was
Spanish and he dropped a tray of glasses
and all the glasses broken he only
berated the kid and fire them the
Sinatra went up to him and said how much
for each [ __ ] glass
the guy's like what are you talking like
it was how much for the glasses
there's not another $1 piece he gave him
the money because next time I company
that kid better work here I'm gonna tell
all my friends not the [ __ ] come here
don't hit like that yeah he was you know
but listen without him there's no Sammy
Davis jr. no this was because nobody
wanted to see a black entertainer yes I
mean that's not just that [ __ ] you
he's with me you know I think as soon as
he said he's with me the whole country
was like alright we like that black guy
yes it that was I made was that simple
that this country was all added dog I
remember all of my friends a house and
he met one night and the mother was like
going on and on about I remember one
time for $2 we saw Sinatra this guy that
guy my friend goes and Jazzy Jeff and
The Fresh but those were the stories I
grew up with and all the little
personality traits in 98 I read a script
it was called the Jimmy Roselli story
my manager company goes the cast Oh
who's your manager who was who you were
back then judge Evelyn Jeff Gump yeah
yeah because I have a script B to read I
sold you on the casting director what it
was it was the guy that did Drugstore
Cowboy mm-hmm it was his movie and they
were starring John Travolta and they
were looking for a comedian and I read
the script I was interesting because I
had heard the story before
that the story was that there was a guy
that was better than Sinatra Sinatra
will tell you mm-hmm Sinatra will tell
you that the guy was better his name was
Jimmy Roselli
Jimmy Roselli was from Hoboken New
Jersey and he Sinatra hired him to sing
at his mother's birthday and rozelia to
show up so it was a sign of disrespect
so Roselli told anybody who gives him
worked I don't do work for Sinatra told
Sinatra laid the [ __ ] ground workout
bandim the [ __ ] guy's record label
fire them everything the guy would have
to tape out and sell him out of the
trunk of his car he was the original MCM
come on and the Italians would go Jimmy
close the [ __ ] trunk you're
embarrassing us come over here will give
you the tender giving you sit there and
sell [ __ ] house so what he had to do
was go on the road with comics oh so he
would open up for comics and sing a song
and then the comics from globster was
very vaudvillian
so when I read the script yeah you know
I read the script it was down to two
comics me and everybody loves Molly
Molly uh Mike oh you mean Billy Gardell
Billy Gardell yeah yeah they liked us so
much that they said [ __ ] it we just want
to hire both tears that was the audition
that I snorted coke till 6:15 I had to
go in there when I got with the room
Travolta was in the room
like it was real once you got to the
audition Travolta was back was this
before or after BASEketball this was
after basketball this is when I was
getting my [ __ ] together was about mm
yeah I was getting my [ __ ] together they
got that I was going to acting class I
got that script and I had to go across
from the Burger King on Western that's a
bad [ __ ] name yeah I know where that
is there's a little office and then
that's all tip-top Magoo they gave you a
water like a white person didn't even
know was there yeah that's where the
director from Drugstore Cowboy and who
is that my Fincher right no I forgot
what his name is and
Travolta were in the callback for all
the cocaine high evaporated when I
walked in like that residual I'm feeling
you get
you drink around with juice cuz man Sam
because of ancestor or his juice then he
took an extra step and came and watch me
at the store Gus Van Zandt
so they were in they were in my magic
squad Florida have a great time at a
time you come back you start shooting
first names a lot of the phone rings -
Walter back that to do the Scientology
movie
oh the Battlestar Galactica star you
like bad move on this bar Jimmy Roselli
story went [ __ ] hon [ __ ] hurt can
I tell you something it's it's kind of
probably the way you know considering
how his life went I'm not surprised
that's what happened to the movie you
know what I mean like he was gonna be
big again and then all of a sudden he's
not and now where is he now who Travolta
know whatever like what happened - I
know he's probably dead but what
happened to Jimmy Roselli he's probably
dead I mean but what happened to his
career he did nothing nothing I don't
know what the whole story how it ended
up I forget to be honest I forget how
the script ended up and what happened
from typing Jimmy Rizzo
dude you know when the first time I met
Billy Gardell it was when I was running
that room at the Union remember that
room it was right that that one of my
favorite rooms ever because it was I
like small rooms eternity they get hot
and they get loud I have still to this
day I think I've told you this before
but I've never the most I've ever seen
anyone murder a room is Rogan in that
Rogen loo the best of his life in that
room because it was so small and it was
like Pac and standing a lot of good said
that uh a BOTS stepping on his mother's
[ __ ] who despite that was also the
first time I heard his joke which is
still one of my favorite jokes ever
which is you know I told my girlfriend I
wanted a titty [ __ ] and she said how
you gonna make that feel good for me and
I said I'll tell you what right when I'm
about to come
I'll stop punching you in the face
with the first time I met Billy Gardell
was in that room Rogen had was buddies
with him and I'd brought him had brought
him from the East Coast or I don't know
if they're still buddies but they were
buddies and Billy was wearing those Cab
Calloway white and black dress shoes
yeah so we're [ __ ] everywhere
and Joe was like you my kin my buddy get
up I'm like yeah whatever but he was
dressed like you know he always had a
suit in that [ __ ] he was Billy
Gardell used to dress it up you know the
in those shoes would look like biggie
yeah he would walk into a room but yeah
absolutely I see him from time to time
he's still a sweetheart he's a great guy
yeah I see I bumped into him where he
has cars you sure yeah [ __ ] he's a
sweet boy bentham red in Burbank yeah I
was away there's one coffee shop I
always run into him here in LA and that
Union man was uh that top of that room
was like a little barroom you know the
difference between like a little when
you do a one-nighter like difference
between those big stages Oh have you
been doing Stata well the very first
time I did it I was 15 right and then
you know I did it once maybe again in
high school and then I did a comedy
competition the next time I got on stage
in in San Antonio and the fourth time I
was ever on stage I opened for Sam
Kinison so I was like oh this comedy
[ __ ] is easy you know I mean like I'm
not been on stage four times and I'm
opening for Kennison because I've told
you this story right yeah yeah so but ya
know and then I I took a lot of time off
here in town which I regret in the time
that I took off if I'm being honest with
ya when I was writing on shows when I
was writing on yes dear and writing on
staff and when I was writing for a
little bit on Chelsea I didn't get on
stage because my deal with Beth was I'm
gone enough I'm not gonna be gone oh if
I wrote on the show then I had to put
stand up to the side because I couldn't
write during the day and go out there at
night do you know I mean I had to have a
little life life work balance and so I
took a
a bunch of time off from stand-up and I
were and I really would now regret that
because right now on the road I'm like
I'm like oh that's right and finally
because about a year and a half ago man
there was a huge switch huge switch for
me I finally accepted what I do well I
always kind of knew what I do well but I
always fought against it a little bit
and about a year and a half ago I
finally accepted it and was like this is
just the comic you are man you you can't
try to be a different person anymore and
it changed the entire changed the entire
thing my comedy was always okay in my
brain people always had a good time but
the last year and a half or so it's been
a different beast because I've I'm I'm
truly just being myself and having a
good time on stage and it's changed
every issue of time how what time I'm is
so [ __ ] stand-up ish like it's such a
cliche thing to say but it's just like
anything else it's time yeah it's time
like when you think it when you couldn't
comment on years you in the back you had
you think you have a figure that yeah
but it's not even close mmm it's it's
weird
I was don't comment about 9 years 10
years and I member thinking I don't know
what the [ __ ] I was thinking I just knew
that I thought I was on the right path
or whatever I was doing I was a regular
at the store and I saw Paul Rodriguez
killing and I walked into the main room
and he sucked me and I walked in and
Mitzi was sitting up thinking she gonna
sit here and I can watch him go wow this
is magical [ __ ] and she goes you see
what happened it's at 20 years and I
remember thinking [ __ ] I gotta do this
10 more [ __ ] years what the [ __ ] it
isn't that I wasn't 1 or something and
you're telling me I gotta do this 10
more [ __ ] years to get that good and
then I remember being in the game about
16 years
and I wasn't really in love with it
anymore like I just didn't see a purpose
for it
yeah well the realities were setting it
in my mind the realities were setting in
I was out here I had shot movies had
done TV shows and it just wasn't going
my way
that's it there was no excuse I had
given it everything I had about like
2006 I was really [ __ ] sick like I
got blown smoke up my ass
you know mm-hmm and I bought it it was
too what I wanted to hear so the
addiction got worse things weren't
happening I thought the phone was gonna
ring off the hook I did everything I was
supposed to [ __ ] do and I said [ __ ]
this I'm not gonna wallow I'm gonna go
to the Improv every Thursday and not
tell nothing nobody walking the side
watch the headliner and I did that for
about 12 weeks I just went down and I
didn't say nothing to nobody
I watched greg Giraldo I watched Ralphie
I watched I think it was Bill burr I
watched just whoever was cracking at
that time and I was like bro I am the
farthest thing from that like I really
am the farthest thing from that I'm the
headliner at this 16 year mark the 15
year mark I was like I'm not Adler it's
just never gonna work this is just I
remember going I laugh the Longest Yard
and just eat and dick like people coming
to see me because of the movie and me
just eating a bag of dicks and thinking
[ __ ] I've been jealous now for 14 years
can I tell you the people who first when
Chelsea first hit and we were headlining
clubs or going and doing theaters the
people who first saw me then I apologize
I mean I thought in that moment yeah
this is yeah I don't know this is it a
weird but I it's it's it's a different
the listen I learned a lot from watching
you dude because what I learned from
watching you is that at some point you
just said [ __ ] it this is who I am and
I'm gonna ride or die with Who I am
with Who I am
how many people when you first got to
town told you to clean Oh - Duke oh not
to swear and how many be not to swear to
sell your show on TV to make your image
likeable to make your image so I could
write a TV show every everybody was
something that was but but you were
disturbing yeah listen you know when we
first started I remember your jokes were
terrible but when you got mad and you
were you onstage
you ripped that place up and I [ __ ] I
mean both of us and we obviously young
Tom's at the time but we we should have
picked up to the fact
oh when he's being himself he's tearing
this place down but when we were writing
jokes
it was dick dick that's it that you
write so what I learned that you were
just like and so what happened to you
doesn't happen to most people hitting
you laughter 50 right after 20 years of
stamina going to Columbus the first time
his Adler and just dying a slow death
this had to be when I first saw him with
Justin first time Justin called me I
think we can gave me Cobb and something
else just to see we liked each other how
this thing worked
hmm I think Portland helium was when we
had our first disagreement about
something how deep into the podcast were
you at that time maybe a year maybe a
year and a half into the podcast once
when I was doing Beauty and the Beast
that was about a hundred people a show
mm-hmm how do people showing up calling
hey we wasn't the Beauty and the Beast
you know so that was the very beginning
ester my module carbs just sell it out
with Felicia and going one to something
this is [ __ ] crazy but my stand-up
wasn't no no not at all it's not ready
at all but here's another thing that so
for me again watching you I know there
are things that were naturally good at
right you are not
really gifted at commanding the stage
storytelling a charisma that allows you
to say things that other people can't
get away with yes one of the things that
has not always been your strength is to
sit and write but the fact that you make
yourself do that you've turned yourself
into a writer like there that it's it's
amazing like the writing jokes is not
easy and then the discipline to do it is
also not easy you give yourself listen
we've been here yeah let's talk the
particulars you were in the major weeks
last week something happened that was
kind of weird okay a finer one of my
favorite fighters I love her to death
came in seven pounds over now we don't
know what the strategy is some people
have a speculation that's what she
wanted you know you only lose 30% of
your purse you know making Hillary has a
lot of percentage that's a lot of
percentage but you're not yeah yeah and
let the UFC tell you to go down but at
the end of the week seven pounds all
seven pounds is a lot that means where
his run was a joke and you know ba ba ba
ba she's beautiful and I love her you
Jitsu are you jitters money i watch a
role in her [ __ ] money I watched her
against Gabby Garcia with no giegi Gabby
Garcia is a girl that's bigger than me
yeah you have to see this woman and
Mackenzie turned rose with her and [ __ ]
at a DCC and all so I really liked her
but the end of the day at the end of the
day after all the jokes are told let's
be honest you're in the UFC
you came in seven pounds overweight in
the biggest form there is for state for
fighting in the world now let's talk
about stand-up in that sense right now
we're at the Comedy Store
right now we're at the podcast right now
there's so many things gonna I cannot
get away with what I was getting away
with ten years ago people will not come
see me if I just go up there high and
try to improvise and be cute he was good
but not good nothing I'm back and watch
I didn't see anything you know each show
you try to be different
every week you try to write you can't
sell a ten thousand dollar car wearing
$10.00 shoes nope that's it I always go
back to that be
at the end of the week we'll [ __ ]
salesman you cannot sell a $10,000
collar with $10 user
I am I gonna buy coffin when you a BMW
with your shoes on shine mm-hmm I so I
went to my agency I saw a kid his pants
was so [ __ ] high if he was my age and
I'd smack him in the face
his pants were four inches over his
[ __ ] dick that's how they're wearing
him that was ready to say and write your
pants down and have a party oh [ __ ] you
know just certain things that I'm happy
that a big agency didn't approach me ten
years ago
hmm I'm [ __ ] ecstatic that a big
manager that approached me ten years ago
because I would [ __ ] Joe the reason we
you know when I had those TV deals early
on if I'm honest with myself I'm the
reason they didn't go because I had
everybody else they were given TV deals
to think about the people who were on
the air
Roseanne Tim Allen Paul Reiser Seinfeld
they had Drew Carey a huge pool of
material for their character they've
been doing stand-up for a long time they
had a huge backbone right of what their
writers could rely on I was given a show
just because of my situation not because
of my comedy you know what I'm saying so
the situation was interesting to the
network's but my cop there was no
stand-up wise I wasn't close to ready so
when they lied they were like Oh late
let's take a look at the situation
single guy raising three kids in one
room perfect we loved it and then when
they went to my comedy to help write the
scripts there wasn't any and it if they
died it died it died because I wasn't
ready for what they were giving me do
you don't I mean and and and it the same
thing with stand-up like right now I
feel like you if you come to my show and
you and you're in you're a fan of mine
you come to my show you know what my
shows are like you're gonna have a good
[ __ ] time
look man you know I made a decision
about a year and a half two years ago
that one of the reasons I had not done
it was because of the people in this
town that I respect so much you know how
many times did you say hey go back on
the road hey put down that little
[ __ ] banjo and I'd be like yeah maybe
I shouldn't but the end of the day I
died start I do 50 minutes to stand up I
do bit which is basically like three
strong stories and then I end the show
with three songs because I like it and
about a year and a half ago I was like
[ __ ] it this is something I like to do
and I don't attack jokes like you do and
now that's what I mean like I had to
accept who I was I tried to it for so
long tried to attack jokes like you or
rogue and Herber because though you were
the guys that I respect and you were the
guys that make me laugh and then I had
to realize that's not I just I'm a
little sillier than that you know what I
mean and I just had to accept the fact
like that's just [ __ ] Who I am yes
yeah yeah the art has no boundaries
right y'all just expect you to be funny
how you get there is your [ __ ] German
man yeah how you get there is how you
hang that TV up on the wall it's up to
you but it's I don't give a [ __ ] are you
hanging up as long as you hang up you
want to hang out with hangers I'm
telling you to use this [ __ ] thing
[Laughter]
this is what you get yeah that's but it
took me because when you are in business
with people that you respect and you
admire you can't help but want them to
be like oh I think he's funny too and at
some point I had to be like [ __ ] that
I'm not performing for them you know
what I mean it'd be nice but I'm not
performing for them you know what I
learned early on I saw people give up
their things for stand-up and I didn't
like it give up there what who they are
yeah for the sake of the town I figured
out this way I did movies and did TV
shows and I was an okay stand-up but
there was still something missing I knew
there was still something missing I knew
that you know what yeah I have success
there that's where the strength comes
from is putting down the ego what you
just said is a beautiful thing about why
the shows in young get picked up a lot
of can I was ten years ago you weren't
saying that he was saying something
completely different or ten years ago I
was blaming yeah you wait you see this
in your journey you learn all these
things in you whatever journey you
choose whether it's a dentist a lawyer a
doctor a stand-up there
[ __ ] same journey you're gonna feel
different about it when you did twenty
years in and ten years and then five
years then six months in it's that you
stuck with it and that's how you really
[ __ ] learn it like you were like now
I know like listen I'm 55 and I'm a
[ __ ] black belt in jujitsu black
poppins did someone black belt and stand
up yeah a couple red stripes yeah and
you gotta had the life aspect to it
like I seen prison I seen people getting
stabbed I've also seen a woman give
birth twice you know
we saw a guy raised three kids by
himself with no mom I saw some shitty
[ __ ] but I also saw some beautiful [ __ ]
my my range to draw from you want to get
down we get down I got talked about
putting a balance and chicks [ __ ] and
blood came on the baby and I fainted
[ __ ] you know there's so much diversity
to talk yeah going to prison you know
got into you I got a [ __ ] prison and
I tried to go back to college and they
wouldn't let me find then I have taken
the court to be allowed to go to night
classes I get my degree and after I beat
them I took 3 credits like you know what
yeah like I had all these [ __ ] trials
and tribulations because at 25 I had
what I wanted had wife a kid and a job
and I was going to school and I was
making a little bit of money like if
this is my wife is shoot me now yeah
might shoot me now yeah this is it five
days a week I work Saturdays I watch the
kids Sunday I go to our parents and
watch the Buffalo Bill game shoot me
down and when I'm 65 I got a gold watch
and happy retirement shoot me now shoot
me now I can't don't tell me this was
what I thought I meant for all these
years I
snorting coke I was having a good time I
was breaking into people's houses I was
having a great time by myself and I'm
sitting here watching TV with a woman
telling me they're done no no I couldn't
do it at 25 you know what you know what
is somebody said to me recently though I
had never thought of because I know how
you grew up and uh they said that poor
people have dreams rich people don't
rich kids on a drink why don't they get
everything you want because we were
talking about entertainment people and I
go mostly mostly and of ten people I
know grew up kind of on the lower end of
the money scale the guy was I can't
because poor people have dreams and they
don't let go of those dreams because
they're always in their head since at a
young age dreaming of a way out dreaming
of something better and that it man
I'm the same [ __ ] way right you're
all we're always that would never work
for you because you always dreamt of
something better of a different life I
just dreamt a lot sleep on my couch yeah
being able not to go to work I did not
want any money
like I just wanted enough money that I
could go outside and get a soda in the
daytime in the paper maybe a salami
sandwich from stands up at the corner I
was good I was lazy I didn't wanna
listen I just needed existence
I still remember going to see a
counselor before you leave prison and
they go you know I don't know if you
know this you could file for Social
Security you're a felon you're disabled
that was my control company this a week
and they were like at six 600 a month or
something they'll help you they'll pay
for an apartment for you and I was like
I was almost saying like if it was 1,200
yeah and friend was rent-free in his
shield apartment that would have been my
life Josh I know I'm nobody I love
movies I love TV you know I love smoking
pot if I could have figured out a way
justice there was just a time in my life
why just wanted to be left alone a
little shitty apartment like that in
Boulder I paid 400 for a [ __ ]
one-bedroom it was the loo now that same
thing as 1600 1800 apartment but the
point being is I didn't need much I was
pretty and if I could snort coke
we go but then I would go to subways and
I would go to different restaurants and
I would see those old dudes with the
ponytail yeah with the shirt of Molly
Hatchet mm-hmm spring an 83 tour and the
other kids are like Jacob's age and
they're telling so you really saw that
Zach please I can't man I looked at that
guy I'm gonna go that's what I'm gonna
be and that can't happen either
yeah I never wanted to be the cool guy
like that that's so I gotta find the
happy medium and then I went after
everything I thought you know oh my god
I could I tried to get the best jobs
with the felony with a GED and no
college education like I was already
getting interviews for places like that
the samel pharmaceuticals started at
60,000 like I was getting I was
bullshitting my way in those doors yeah
like I was that good at [ __ ] in my
way in those doors but then that calming
thing kept coming back like I'm gonna
watch a movie and go [ __ ] I gotta figure
out how to do comedy but what was it
about comedy in the movie that made me
lose my mind them first movie I saw that
I left hand going was splash yeah but
that wasn't standard that was 84 still I
didn't know what I didn't know what the
route was I just wanted to be able to do
what John Candy was doing I was like
damn I had to figure out how to do it
John Candy stole and then that's 84 yeah
in 87 I got locked up right about that
time a week before I got two weeks
before I got I kidnapped that dude two
weeks before that went down this is how
life works I got told argument with a
guy named grant a lot I thought about
how hard about this name his name was
great and he was a white dude and he was
[ __ ] built and then one of my cocaine
tirades for the next morning I went off
on him about a custom and we went neck
to neck we're gonna punch the [ __ ] out
of each other the manager came out broke
this up where are you working at the
time
I was working in bill crowd Subaru
mm-hmm and they said listen just stay on
the opposite side of the stores for a
couple weeks and don't talk to him and
you don't talk to him we we said
everything we had to say to each other
we had sell everything we had to say we
both call each other [ __ ] and [ __ ]
you and yeah yeah punch me first and
I'll punch you first so it was cool we
went to managers meetings to found one
week and you know like a week later I
was standing on the opposite side of the
stone he came up to me and he goes Amen
I know you don't like me but he goes you
know what I did for the last 20 years I
was an entertainer in Las Vegas I'm just
looking at this didn't what are you
getting to like what the [ __ ] are you
talking about
I was just thinking about going home and
going online a call go I was gonna
[ __ ] you know whatever that night
yeah and he goes you have a career in
stand-up comedy cuz I've seen all of
them and I could tell that you your
stand-up cop thing like that's great and
I just went on with my business and then
when I got locked up and I started doing
those shows on Thursday nights exactly
grant Miami pulling everything just
pointed to it the door was right there
and then I came out and got a job and it
was all forgotten about my time to come
with a Christian in jail yeah mighty you
throw the book up in the air saying it
was like that like in prison for a while
I was writing jokes
there was no resources there was no
internet right you know I didn't know
about Judi Carter I didn't know about
nothing I just was just writing on a
notebook about black people white people
I didn't [ __ ] it though because I was in
prison yeah that was my whole shtick
with white people bikers black people
and [ __ ] the Italian fat cooked
that's it that was my material so I had
to work with so once I got out of prison
I was like I don't know stand up that
was just a pipe dream
do you remember I remember my for the
first joke I told on that comedy and I
was thinking about this because I ran
over an old flier of a show me you and
Brody did in Seattle years ago right
when I started thinking about what time
was out what jokes was I telling and
then I
yeah I actually found an old notebook
and I remember the first joke I ever
told on the comedy underground stage was
this was that I had I was poor and so I
had gone to the sperm bank to see about
donating the sperm egg and I was
surprised to know that you had to apply
and I was even more surprised to find
out that they accept less than 6% of
their applicants 6ms means it's hearts
statistically harder to get into the
sperm bank than it is into Harvard Law
School and you know what that means that
means that there's a lot of picky
[ __ ] lesbians
that was my first joke I ever told on
that stage and I remember thinking
that's the smartest joke I'll ever write
you know what I mean
you know that first one where you're
like this is your ever I'm expecting
like a just dude you know what's really
weird cuz I do it it seems like every
whenever you start cuz I had one like
everyone has one was like a stat in it
and everyone has like something based on
a song sure I guess on lyrics it's funny
like you that like whenever I go up on
my oh this person's new that they're
doing something about that oh I looked
this up and there's 80% I'm like so
there's a percentage point in it that
means you're new I don't know what it is
because the stat tells you that they're
trying to seem like they're smart tommix
I'm going to do a little research on the
interwebs and find out that 8% like and
it doesn't mean [ __ ] but I that
underground those over mics some of my
best memories I totally that I stir them
to get there on a Friday night and then
that was the first thing I said to that
crazy [ __ ] I go show me this club you
saw yeah and we took the car ride and we
walked around and I went in and I'm
looking in the window it was a bar and
I'm like like I was there like oh my god
this is the comedy underground the
[ __ ] figure with the eat in the
building and yet I was like oh my god
this is this is different I went right
down there that
and you walked in and you're from Boston
little perfect guy from the East Coast
at least I got a landline mm-hm and that
was it it was like I remember starting
first like the first couple open mics
you go from one then maybe you moved to
number two yeah then you gonna number
four and then by the end that was the
number fifteen guys closing it out and
have [ __ ] feels great
it really did man I felt like just the
pecking order of you know I sit here now
like today I just announced at the
Netflix thing listen this is a
blue-collar mentality like the way I did
comedy was blue collar
I did a blue collar the whole way I just
went back to the basic rules just keep
getting onstage they're gonna throw
tomatoes at you at events they won't
throw tomatoes you know you go on stage
or the fireman's hat without you know
they're throwing [ __ ] I and I knew I
just I didn't have nothing else to do
well since I know what the [ __ ] was that
gonna do here yeah in 2007 you think I
was really just gonna quit stand now and
get a job selling cars like that's what
I was planning no in 2010
I went over to that forged or how
[ __ ] crazy is that
in 2010 I went over there for three
interviews got the job and they wanted
me to go piss in a bottle and I pull the
guy oh my god that's not a [ __ ] he
knows what are you talking about no put
three hands he Doughboy the other stuff
yeah I want to go with shout out thick
Kathryn preach meg Tucson Lou Russ ex
Eric Shawn James Diaz Jeff slaughter
Paul Lynch and patio furniture you
badass [ __ ] help me remember let me do
a bun just to get the party started
yeah well you know I was telling Lanie
today how you go to the open mic and at
first you're number one on the list yeah
you take the bull of the death you do
that like three weeks in a row and what
saved us was that we had a mentor hand
of Mike
like that was big like that was big like
my fare junkie he cared he Carl
genuinely cared not just about where he
worked in the comedy underground Carl
cared about comedy he [ __ ] loved
comedy so as goofy as he was he wanted
to make sure that was a good show and if
he didn't think you were doing something
right in his way he would tell you oh he
had such an influence um yeah I think
about it now at the first person who
influenced me was him like he pulled me
aside and said do this joke here
you're insulting people do this yeah and
then he did something me one day he made
me follow a ring google it and I will up
I don't know this [ __ ] guy and that's
why it's better not to know who the [ __ ]
I kind of learned the big lesson that
day you don't need to know who anybody
is
just go up didn't do your material it
doesn't matter goes in front mm-hmm
that's how I became friends with Rick do
commit because I found him I don't know
Mike he was working on some HBO stuff
yeah like I'm working on some aids Bo
stuff and I didn't know who the [ __ ] he
was nothing give a [ __ ] yeah I just come
home from a fight with Kara dirty talk
about him is or whatever yeah and I went
up there and foul him but I had a good
set he came up with me after what he
does not a lot of people could have
followed me that's pretty good stick
with it and then when I got here I
called him for a lot of counseling he
having his wife were [ __ ] brilliant
they know exactly that I just keep on in
two spots you're doing the right thing
he goes I would go down to the improv
after the show was done and buy drinks
for people and put spotlights out in the
back and do it it's all about what you
want I thought of his wife and writing
meal for dinner one night yeah and she
was telling me how he did Letterman and
the next day they drove from New York to
where she's from and Ohio and they drove
all night and got there like an eight in
the morning and that five o'clock they
ate dinner and he was putting his shoes
on and she goes way you're gonna goes
there's an open mic that on the corner
at the pizza place I'm gonna go do it
you cuz you just didn't let him he goes
exactly that was yesterday
yeah he goes that's your mentality
that's but it has to be that she has to
be him in town there
was a kid that was open enough for me
and I forget which city it was he was
hosting right Freya who said he was but
he was I asked him because he was pretty
funny
and I said you one do this full-time and
he goes yeah I know how many nights you
getting onstage a week and he said I do
three sets a week I go you should quit
I said quit and he said why I said you
know look I'm gonna give you an example
I say Joe Rogan is in in LA for a week
and he's doing stand-up he'll do three
sets sometimes in a night and if one of
the best guys in the world is sometimes
tripling the amount of times you're
getting onstage and night you're not
trying hard enough if you're getting
into stand-up just getting into it and
it's what you want to do forever and
ever and ever and ever and you only
figure out your how to get on Sage twice
a week it's gonna be tough looking for
98 to 2007 I had two editions it was
just you used to keep a folder or how
many times you got on stage and you had
do you still have that [ __ ] bonus I
do you you said in a number you said a
weekly a monthly and a yearly number yes
I did yeah how many years did you do
that I remember I remember that [ __ ]
notebook 96 till today you it was a
weekly month and sometimes I remember
you to stick to it you would be like I
got one more [ __ ] set I got to do I
don't care if it's at a pizza place I
got a matter I got a sign you had one
more and you would make sure I stood in
front of a [ __ ] mic doesn't Larry
remember that thought you know drove me
crazy yeah I was in [ __ ] I was just
I got a do I remember that in Denver I
worked my ass off to do 16 spots a month
and it was I would drive to Cheyenne
Wyoming yeah like this is two hours to
do an open mic I would kill it on
Fridays go up there early get the shrimp
and lobster sauce add some Chinese right
ha ha ha ha a bunch of New Yorkers in
Cheyenne Wyoming yes I did I would drive
to Cheyenne for Collins
Riverton Wyoming to do the open mic I
would drive bro oh I know they I don't
know what the [ __ ] people are talking
about and then I got here and once I got
here I knew that it was three spots at
night nearly pays another Mexican bar
for Rudy's and that was it and you know
what I forgot about my health I mean I
was so yeah and to stand up that health
oh you had no balance and it all bounds
without no balance that there was no
balance but here's the [ __ ] crazy
thing then you just remind me you know
many times I walked in the door because
this was the process just so people know
I would go to the county store get a
package put it in my drug pocket from
Chewy's hat it could be from anybody and
I would put it in my pocket and it would
stay there till I got off stage as soon
as I got off stage and went right to the
bathroom did that first bump I went to
the bar I drank a little bit and once I
felt the coke I'd leave I didn't want to
get coked up in public to watch no that
was never your day so I go home and let
me tell you something no I'd stop I get
beers two packs of camels three packs of
camels I'd have a grandma coke first
thing I did up before I walked in into
the line of coke open up beer was I go
piss and then I go right for the
notebook and before I did that line of
coke as addictive as I was I would write
for a bull did okay gotta work on that
joke The Improv I ate a bag of dicks I
did the same and The Comedy Store I did
perfect I just need to write this I
didn't like how I said that I thought I
don't know had a date how much time what
I got paid for each set I did the same
[ __ ] thing that was it that was the
first thing I did when I got home there
was no calls
there was no cocaine there was nothing
the first thing I did when I walked
through that door as much as I wanted to
start to cook was open up that notebook
and write exactly how I did what I got
paid and what I tried and what died and
as honest and as would yeah this could
be you know it's funny he said I had one
of those too
where I would write down where I was
what I did how much I got paid how much
time I did to the other one I wrote down
so I didn't have a how many sets a week
notebook I because I didn't have because
of the kids I didn't I I knew I didn't
have that ability to get as many sets
that I wanted I kept track of phone
calls
that I made for myself for my career
there were certain amount of phone calls
a day every day some something it's
something I can do some I am busy yeah
yeah yeah you work for yourself yeah
your own corporation that's it if you
sit there in a day time and watch TV and
look at the computer that's exactly what
your career when you're stealing money
from yourself you're just stealing money
from yourself that's why you have to
have a schedule you get up at 8:00 you
have a breakfast you go exercise get it
out of the way yeah then you're gonna
come home wash your [ __ ] go right for
an hour and a half then you go home
because you can't sit there like a
[ __ ] I can't do it I gotta go
somewhere right yeah yeah then you go
get a job from 12:00 to 8:00 someone
[ __ ] tape on the phone whatever and
then from there you get on your [ __ ]
car and you go start doing your spot you
get a little dinner in and you go do
your spots and you know I still remember
that at the end of the notebook like at
the end of the notebook it would be this
last sheet would be what I made that
year Sony is even gonna grab a blow
I wouldn't the night before New Year's
I'm gonna grab a blow and add every
month up so I would add it up in the
corner so January February March was a
corner yeah when I made and I still
remember looking at that paper and it be
saying $8,000 for me $8,000 is what I
made in comedy in 1996 for the year yeah
man I figured out how to do blow pay
child support part-time [ __ ] bike
club you know you figure out how to not
buy underwear
I don't need underwear no I need six
pairs of socks
I've never wore underwear never know
it's like you just figured out what you
need it to do what you need what if they
do we used to uh so I had my bills on an
alternate month payment not that not
that the companies were okay with that
that's just how I paid my bills I paid
my bills like by which one was getting
turned off that month and that's the one
that got paid and the other ones that
weren't getting turned off I'll see you
next month she's so weird how you get
addicted to this dream and next thing
you know you live in the house with a
guys on
but you don't give a [ __ ] dude cuz
you're doing 22 spots a week but are
eating ramen [ __ ] selling cigars at a
[ __ ] phone company from 6:00 to 8:00
on Saturdays you work a door because
what's the difference nobody's giving
you working on the weekends you're just
making money during the week catering
catering in people's houses on fire yeah
it's so you know and you look at it you
go
maybe you're [ __ ] for all those
years but now I thought like was that we
were cuz I don't leave it after about
three years four years one night that
does come a day that for four years it's
just one night cuz it's like a fighter
or anybody else we don't know what we're
gonna get it could even be 200 punches
before we start hearing people yelling
or it can be four punches you never know
what it is yeah but there's that one
night where you just pop your head up
and you look around the room and go what
the [ __ ] okay so two things one you know
there was a time when I was in the
luxury apartments with the kids I don't
know if I've told you this but my dad
came in and had a serious talk to me and
he said I'm really respect the fact that
you were going after what you love and
you're following your dreams but at what
point does that become selfish
you now have three kids how long do they
have to live like this how long are you
gonna follow your dreams at their
expense and he said I'm not telling you
to quit I would never tell you to quit
you know we'll support you but at what
point are is what you're doing selfish
and I was like well that is a really
[ __ ] great question and to be honest
with you like the I was gonna do that
one-man show and I was gonna see what
happened for six months or so but I had
he was right at some point I had to stop
to prioritize the dream over the kids
and what they were getting right but
also on what I told my dad was I also I
don't mind them struggling I want as
long as they see that we're still the
fight you know we're fighting it for
what we want but I'll tell you something
you know that moment you you're talking
about where you lift your head up and
you go what the [ __ ] am I doing here
that happened to me not for years in
that happened to me [ __ ] four years
ago four years ago what happened is that
we yeah it happens every three years
yeah normal if you have any normality
you find yourself at The Comedy Store
1:45 you got it because it never ends
see it never ends listen you know I
can't imagine being louis c.k at Kevin
Hart sounds terrible dude I just saw
Tiffany Haddish in another movie I know
so it's nice to be in demand but there
comes a point that you just lose
yourself and I have lost myself and I
don't ever want to go back there again
yeah there comes a point that you really
lose yourself and this we've seen people
Pro losing we know people who committed
suicide think I was thinking about him
yeah they're the kid they used to put
the ink of hunt the Seattle oh yeah
you know I bumped into somebody I dare I
had to come he with 19 years ago and bro
it's not bad it's PTSD from what this
town that time yeah a little bit success
and then he couldn't cover the spread
which happens to a lot of people hostile
anyone away and if you see him now
joyful anyway oh boy this is no boy
though first of all it's one of the
reasons I went last night by the way
Rudy Moreno was funny that Rudy Sarzo
once made a comment down here when I
first had him on and he goes I don't
know he goes out he goes I've been
around comedian since cavesson and
musicians anybody ever been to the room
where it's a fine line between mental
health and art like there's a lot of
comics I know that in the beginning like
in the beginning economy those open mics
could become dangerous like [ __ ]
cuz it's still got a bracelet on from
the [ __ ] loony bin you know I'm
saying an open mic in New York and some
guys like I just got let out yeah after
30 days I'm okay and he had the bracelet
remember that homeless clown that came
onstage at the underground Jesus it was
it was it
horrendous yeah you're looking at this
going maybe this is me just from a
different angle this could be me yeah
you know I always tell the story but the
guy that would go up on stage every
Monday this is my impersonation of a
bird that's my favorite coming in is
that's that's my story the story of OPI
and he would just go up he was very
happy he knew who he was yeah he was
like the character the Godfather you
could put stickers all over the wall he
didn't care he didn't care he knew who
he was and he would go up on a stage
every Monday number seven yeah he had a
day job he was happy as [ __ ] he had ten
people have come see him every Monday
Eddie go up on stage and say this is my
play station of a boy this is my
impersonation of a shoe this one on for
[ __ ] months you know and when you're
a comic like you're like okay it's cute
you figure it out he's not gonna wear
like you know right away like five five
that's 19 that's 96 I mean comedy five
years now I'm like this guy he's not
going anywhere but it's okay he ain't
bothered nobody but after a year and a
half on this thing to this every Monday
like this is my impersonation of a man
and traffic on the farm yeah how awfully
change him what do you mean what do you
write new stuff every week a new
impersonation topic yeah he wouldn't
impersonate know by now oh you wouldn't
do anything oh he would just go this is
my impersonation of a Boston Red Sox
yeah
this is what yeah Jim Morrison at the
Hollywood Bowl oh my god yeah this is my
so it's cute at the beginning you know
what is none of my business but he's
having a good time having a great time
he had his little girlfriend would come
or a little boyfriend oh yeah somebody
would come and see him but one night
you're in a bad mood you just got out of
jail you know saying like I just got out
of County Jail I made the open mic I'm
happy I made the open mic I know I'm
gonna eat and all of a sudden I'm
walking past and he's up there with that
[ __ ] this is my
aw bug I don't know if it was me or
somebody yelled you that was here why
don't you do an impersonation of a comic
and you could hear his whole body a
great body but it was what we had all
been thinking for months and he never
did he come back I think he didn't come
back nothing he switch doctor giggles
what about okay you know you know the
impersonator up there that made me laugh
the most was the guy who sounded like
Jimmy Stewart but he never did an
impersonation of Jimmy Stewart but every
impersonation he did sounded like Jimmy
Stewart doing an impersonation of
somebody but he never acknowledged it so
it was like this is me you know I can't
do it Jimmy Stewart impersonation but
he'd say this is my impersonation of
Jack Nicholson and it just sounded like
Jimmy Stewart reading Jack Nicholson
lines and I talked to him after one of
the shows I go you know that's actually
funny you know that's a whole different
take on it and he was you know he was
like I don't think I sound like Jimmy
Stewart I'm like yeah yeah yeah it's
really rough to talk to comics at that
level yeah and explain to them what you
see because this so I was the same way
people come up to me and say [ __ ] yet
it's so weird I forced myself to go to
an open mic a few times a week though
cuz I don't want to get over whatever
with the Comedy Store so I rather hide
yeah and let every time I go I think
about I'll sit there and watch the open
my courage I go to the fourth wall I'll
sit down watching in ten minutes in
eight minutes said my mind goes back to
being in New York City mm-hmm and when I
was feeling at that time like a 93 like
this is what I want to do when the [ __ ]
am i driving a limo I feel so lucky dude
that we that I started into comedy on
the ground I feel so lucky to have
started in that scene the comedy
underground the original commie
underground is still my favorite stage
ever it's still there
no it's gone it's gonna the earthquake
but gonna get replaced now there's a new
comedy underground but it's not it's
nothing it's not even close it doesn't
have you know there was so much history
in that cellar dude and you remember you
could smoke in there
so by the end of the Late Show there was
like a
layer of smoke just on the top of the
room and it was just dirty and raw but
the energy in that place was [ __ ]
great
and I felt lucky starting there like I
said because Carl was there to kind of
guide all of us in the right direction
and it was a great [ __ ] scene man I
mean I mean Carl was my first [ __ ]
midsi yeah I was thinking a sudden II
heard they Josh when I called you we
were talking the other day and I was
thinking about one of my most ridiculous
days of my life but this is the most
ridiculous day of my life this had to be
in the top five
you leave Seattle I get a job working
for a company that sells advertising to
pizza companies and they're gonna buy it
into every they cut a deal with the NFL
so on Sundays when you're watching
baseball or football or basketball this
is 1997 you moved here in 97 correct yep
this is 97 96 cuz I came in 97 you
already here in nine you came oh and I
save on it came September in 96 and
maybe three weeks I mean I was lost but
I you left and I was lost I have staying
with Carol I was sleeping and [ __ ]
because I was asking myself where the
[ __ ] was I living with the [ __ ] cook
yeah with the cook Oh staying with the
cook and that was great that was like
yeah you know I think about I think
about we happened to stay with that guy
we were [ __ ] gone home every night
was something different either use the
night I woke up and there was three
black guys the room smoking crack yeah I
think I would have [ __ ] died
Lionel Lionel Lionel Lionel was one of
the best young men he lives in New
Hampshire reached out to me on Facebook
does he
yeah I think New Hampshire or something
like Vermont New Hampshire something
like that yeah man we just go there I've
spent a few days I'm like he was just a
great guy he's just a great guy
yes he was a big part of my open mic
fundis yeah like he made open mic so
much fun he did cookies something you
were flat broke yeah and you'd walk in
then his house when I'm in Turkey I
could whip you up a saying you were like
[ __ ] yeah he'd sneak it to you he was
solid yeah if you missed the bus back to
Josh's I could sleep in his house and he
lived in a loft the windows were broken
it was freezing in there he would sleep
and it was [ __ ] freezing in there
yeah
so before you left I get this you leave
and this job opens up $15 an hour
full-time I was like the king of that
nobody could sell like I could sell I
was calling on New York Pizza powers was
going on with Louie I got this thing you
know and I'm selling two or three an
hour
I'm blasting him I get him up to 18 an
hour after two weeks I'm busted I'm
living on the [ __ ] streets I'm taking
showers downstairs I think I even slept
in the hallway one night downstairs I
need this job if I can keep this job
till December I get the [ __ ] out of him
what a lie and sure enough Carol starts
her [ __ ] [ __ ] you owe me money
you owe me money Heather all right meet
me down stairs at 5:00 there was a
Friday she was doing something and I had
a spot at the underground I was doing a
guest spot for somebody at the mm-hmm
she comes downstairs a five I get in the
car with her we go to the [ __ ] back
and she goes I'm not giving you [ __ ]
and I told Carol don't start your
[ __ ] [ __ ] with me right now
and she goes [ __ ] you and she rips the
check at a car wash at the hurricane
call oh yeah she ripped the check and
she [ __ ] smacked me and I grabbed her
by the [ __ ] hair like an animal that
I was and I just pulled the hair real
[ __ ] hard and she's like [ __ ] you
calling the cops so I start [ __ ]
running and there's a [ __ ] I mean
they're a [ __ ]
how I copped is it's true yes you can
so I hide in the trash
it was the dumps of the trash can make
the town Oscar the Grouch I jumped in
the dumpster her thing and I sat in
there with like a twig so I could get
there and bro there was cops everywhere
I mean it was crazy i sat in that thing
for close to six hours that who is that
big Rico another big cop upstairs the
Puerto Rican guy yeah you do and then
I'm in this [ __ ] garbage cans six
hours stinking Eno beats in there they
threw like a somebody's pizza was in
that like that they need the whole pie
but there was like three slices left you
bite you as I leave have pizza you need
John Stehr pizza oh [ __ ] yeah I was
never sick [ __ ] I get out of my hoof
I had like $6 on them like I'm taking
the bus to the underground I'll figure
this soon and there was a movie theater
there it's where I saw Pulp Fiction but
there's I'm walking up the hill the cops
are hiding in the bushes no they knew I
was the garbage can they took paint come
guns out and they arrested me and I
spent the whole week of in jail and they
dropped the charges on Friday there was
no charges oh because this she dropped
the charge she dropped a try and some
[ __ ] happened and but I sat in that
but the whole funny thing about it was
that I jumped out of the garbage can and
I went into this hurricane and I called
Rico and I go Rico I'm in the [ __ ]
bind now Rico was six foot six four
hundred pounds of black dude with a
tattoo of a spider on his face and
designed with his beard yeah so yeah he
shaved his beard to it looked like a spy
spider yeah to top it off he was Muslim
yeah went welcome to Montana one time he
was white diner he got up and got on his
knees and started praying like Rico Rico
was a nice guy any other male he was
telling me was a criminal from the Bronx
and all the issues I know Rico picked me
up on my Perico Rico pull up to the
hurricane I'm at the door watching cops
making patrols I'm like we call about
that I hang up the phone there's no cell
phones and no
there's no cup itself fault I'm looking
through and I see Rico get out of his
car and he's waving in the middle of
street I got we go pull it up and as he
pulls up something happened that's when
I went running and I was I'm running the
[ __ ] cops came out with their [ __ ]
piece and arrested me and I spent the
weekend in jail but I was in the
dumpster from 5 - it had to be 11 make
it to jail for 3:00 in the morning for
my [ __ ] bunk bed and he smelled like
dumpster Isle and I had to wash a shower
there it was clean dumpster the garbage
was on one side then just picked it up
yeah there's got fresh pizza on the
other side a story I don't think it was
fresh I it but then you go man this past
weekend in Cleveland made me realize how
[ __ ] also how fun comedy can be when
you've worked hard
do you know what I mean like his month
it makes me weekend's like this weekend
you know Jackie fabulous is yeah so she
uh Shh
there was a war there would have been
years past where I would have been like
I'm not gonna want her to open front of
me because I'm not gonna well follow
that but uh I found now that thing that
you're saying it doesn't matter who's in
front it just doesn't matter doesn't
matter anymore I don't care like like
nothing bothered me more when I was a
feature act and headliners would
complain about me yeah it would bother
me in a weird way do your job would
bother me like there's a comic colored
and that's the common code if you don't
like it just switch positions just come
in be a man no Joey do me a favor I
can't follow you hey by the way on the
very first Blue Collar Comedy Tour Jeff
Foxworthy is far and away the most
popular guy in the can the tour's being
sold
you know nobody in who Cable Guy was and
Bill Engvall and Ron White and they
didn't know those gay those were by the
ways it was Foxworthy and by the end of
the tour Foxworthy was like Larry you
should close because
what's happening is ridiculous 20
minutes of him was just lighting the
stage on fire especially early on him I
know most people like [ __ ] you I'm
telling you right now you can laugh at
it mock Larry the Cable Guy all you want
we counted one night man when I used to
tour with him dude had 367 punchlines in
his set 367 punchlines and he would turn
a set over every 18 months
it's pretty [ __ ] prolific man they
also had writers Roger Rittenhouse is a
great and good writers did I ever tell
you what what Jacob said to Rittenhouse
no Jacob didn't know Rittenhouse has a
hook and Jacob walked up in Roger and I
were he's backstage talking and Jacob
was like 8 or 9 he walks up in he's
eating chicken wings and Rogers talking
to me Jake it takes a bite I take away
he goes hey what's with the hook and I
go jakey hideous isn't this is a
Halloween like he because the only time
he'd ever seen a person with a hug it
was Halloween you know doggie killed on
stage so funny they're ever the petting
zoo he used to kill on stage yeah Tommy
it's amazing that no no I wish I would
love to hire a writer to help me but
here's the problem the trust issue hmm
even family the trust issue is big
I would love to pay somebody every week
to come out a few nights then but then I
gotta watch them and what the [ __ ] they
do yeah but you so what's so important
for jokes for you is your voice is
really specific really specific right no
that's why I can't do it yeah and do it
because you would even have to you would
have to I'm assuming if someone's
writing jokes for you you'd have to take
the joke and then turn it into your
voice right I would have to flip yeah I
would have to flip it a little bit
anyway stuff you know I've I've really
analyst it's gonna sound weird but
really almost stop I tell pretty much
exclusively long stories you know if I
tell some stories that are there's a
story that I tell it's 23 minutes long
but I've really
writing punchlines 20mins pop up with
the storm yeah yeah yeah if the story
yeah real and you telling the truth yeah
and you know what a story on stage like
listen I told the story by storm cope
with it with a cat and we know wait we
know we didn't look out windows yeah but
that's a mildly exaggeration to make it
funny
that's part of it well you take my story
and you heighten the reality right that
did give the cat coke I did take a coke
rock and he licked it and [ __ ] ran
away and then a month later he came back
and licked it again yeah so it wasn't
that's what it was I tell the story on
stage that I was still in Oakland you
gotta be [ __ ] crazy we think a cat was
snorting coke the here's what I do is
like I'll tell the story exactly how it
happened for the first five times just
to see which part of the truth works and
which part doesn't right but then
sometimes if part of the truth doesn't
work and what's important to me is just
to keep the intent right so like that I
used to tell a joke about
Jacob challenging me to a fight right
and that he that it happens to every the
premise of the joke is like every man at
some point in time when they're growing
up looks at their dad and thinks
themselves oh I could beat the [ __ ] out
of this dude right everybody you look at
their daddy or mentor at least one time
like oh I'm gonna beat the [ __ ] out of
this guy so there was a part where I was
talking about my dad and my brother the
first time I ever saw them fight and the
reality is they were in the kitchen and
my brother Dan kind of pushed my dad and
my dad pushed him really hard back he
picked him up under his underarms and
just ran him into the refrigerator right
so the intent for my dad was yeah you
might be able to do that to me someday
not today is not the day right that's
his his intent and the story but the
action of him picking him up and running
him to the refrigerator wasn't funny
enough it was almost too real right so I
had to cartoon it up a little bit to
make it funny and almost less aggressive
you know saying so but the intent of my
dad and the story is the same I had to
change how he delivered the message and
for me I'm okay with mess
with that stuff as long as I keep the
the core of the story the same the
intent of the story you know what I'm
saying and so if the character has to
change his action a little bit but keep
the same intent so it doesn't change the
story for you I'm totally okay with that
too
that make you know saying no no no
that's the same thing I you tell the
story
23 minutes I would wrap it around
something and keep coming back to it
because I don't want to hit nobody tell
me so every point you might stab you in
the foot it's three it's one story yeah
but it's three different stories in the
story yeah yeah I can't have a 20 people
a you know no no not telling me yeah
it's three different stories in one yeah
yeah yeah it's it's but I tell the story
about going to desert night that with
the stones and the WHO and the McCartney
and Neil Young and Bob Dylan and Roger
Waters I mean it's a story about going
there for the weekend with my brothers
so there's a lot of stories it's one
story but it's a lot of stories you know
that by the way that that weekend made
me I know this is gonna sound so bizarre
made me really appreciate how good of a
rock and roll band
The Rolling Stones are dude I had never
seen them live before I don't heard
their records and when they came out
after the first song Danny seen him a
bunch he goes
you're about to see the good stones he
said some stones concerts Keith doesn't
[ __ ] care and they don't care he said
they're on fire I was blown I guess I
had never
anothers gonna sound like heresy but I
had never given him quit like I'm a who
guy over the stones I always had been
not after that weekend no Dave the
stones are the stones for a reason he's
like when you look at the stones now
really age you like look at these
[ __ ] old guys yeah and look at what
he's trying to do you have to really
look at the 75 3 to 78 stones what
albums are those that's in sticky
fingers well that whole run they did
sticky fingers black and blue ending
with some girls
like that was the that was that was the
result but him I still remember the
destruction some girls was like I'm
really surprised at it into a forty-year
cuz that's when they really were in the
top of that game like that from made in
the shade that one where they went to
Belgium or they went to hide to shoot
the album because they held the taxes I
mean just I mean what did you make gonna
do black and blue like wouldn't that be
great if there was a little [ __ ]
comedy club in Jamaica that you could
say whatever the [ __ ] you wanted to and
you go to Jamaica for six weeks I'm
right an hour that would be great take
your friends down there bring a bag of
reefer blow some chicks and just get a
house and right in a while or like a cat
Kevin Hart type [ __ ] like I'm going to
Jamaica the smoke weed that's what the
stones are doing musically that's what
people were doing that like if you read
the Aerosmith book they would read the
house and Worcester oh yeah great that's
a great great [ __ ] book you know like
they would all live in the house
together
yeah did heroin great book and and Steve
Perry and the other guy weren't talking
it's my favorite rock'n'roll my favorite
book of all oh that's a fake couldn't be
in the same studio together great we're
doing rocks they have tape and rocks
they couldn't be in the same so he would
go in the studio in the afternoon
because he would stay up on my doing a
Helen when he was on Rogan there was
never more of a podcast I wish I could
enjoy knew who was on road Joe Perry
what about two or three years ago was on
Rogen what and I was dying to call and
say ask him where he got the heroin to
shoot rocks first I had one you wanted
him rocks is a brilliant [ __ ] home I
mean one of the favorite Aerosmith album
you know get your way yeah get your
wings I think his broom him the first
one ain't missing a meal either they did
daddy they had a stirrer or five I was
there with all Farley and you should
have seen his face like he had never
heard that type of talk before about
what like I was lying we were listening
to uh oh we listening to was it
Aerosmith Eric never listened to
Aerosmith rocks and my daughter wasn't
born yet and we came on I'm like listen
to this oh he's looking at me all
confused
and I think after that talk we went home
was like I don't know I went off the
dirty Boston people I go you think of
what you think of your struggle
think about the [ __ ] Aerosmith you
weren't just doing it you weren't just
doing a Tuesday in Worcester you were
competing the Celtics for good
the Red Sox were good the [ __ ] Bruins
were good you know everybody was good
the Patriots were like Andre tip it in
whatever ha ha ha what everybody else
you know it's either go see Aerosmith
then go see the Celtics against anybody
and anybody that's when they used to
give 16 points at home there was
actually just great there was a good
music scene in Boston then too there was
a great news yeah but there was no
Twitter no there was no Facebook we know
when those five guys one on tool a Black
Sabbath and 75 well they they toured
they were opening for Sabbath can you
imagine rocks and blacks a habit like
that first album tanked and then they
you've heard you know that story that
I've heard no the first first album
tanked I think they said it sold
something like a ridiculously low number
and then they went on tour and they went
back and they re-released the album Oh
dream on and it blew up or maybe blew up
after they released their second album I
think that's what happened it died a
slow death they they toured and they
toured heavy you know they toured heavy
how they did yeah well you didn't get
off the road cuz the drugs those listen
bro Sabbath wrote and like Sabbath
wasn't off the road when they did master
really and I think that those are made
ours Wow on their way to San Francisco
we're gonna stop in LA and laying out
though it's so bananas that whole
lifestyle has changed yet music is
Chennai even calmly now you shoot a
special and the next week you're on the
road saying that material you just shot
the special for so now other people see
the special they've already seen that
the material yeah the agents don't it's
really weird when I watch that Elvis
a documentary last week on HBO couple of
weeks ago what is the captain said that
line on the colonel yeah he goes he's
[ __ ] wasted
so now just get him out there until
let's kind of as much as we can out of
him you're a piece of meat yeah you're a
piece of this is why I try to explain to
people that this is why you have to stay
grounded in all areas of life because
you're basically a piece of meat and
when you come to that reality it's not a
good reality for you Joe I'm doing III
you know at my age and how long I've
been in this town the fact that I've
just finally figured this out but what
you just said it's why I'm doing what
I'm doing for my career right now
I do things I'm just doing things that I
like I have a good time I'm doing things
that I like and like I said I finally
figured out what it is that I do well
and you know what I am
well III it's kind of irreverent fun
it's a little silly and I've really
started to embrace it and when as I
started to embrace it man I'm more
comfortable with who I am than I've ever
been in my life now I'm more comfortable
on stage I still got my anxiety attack
yeah but I'm still it's wider look my
facebook fanpage and this is I'm slowly
turning it into a tiny little TV network
on Monday night I have live programming
at 7:00 p.m. on Tuesday night I also
have live programming at 7:00 p.m. it's
two things that I just love to do your
mother will do it and people are a
little [ __ ] yeah man I'm gonna pay
attention you know the periscope thing
that you do I do that
basically I call it hi live and for an
hour on my Facebook fan page or seven
o'clock on Mondays we're just shooting
the [ __ ] little guys they can't fool me
Kevin come away I know they can't feel
Brooklyn nine-nine and they canceled the
met which the Fox stood behind one nine
nine they yeah and somebody made a
comment and they said you were getting
two million viewers on Fox what do you
think you're gonna do on HP I'm NBC the
reality of violence Joe Rogan it's 7
million to 10 million people downloading
his pipeline it's believable they get
more than Brooklyn nine-nine
mmm so entertainment right now it's
coming at you from all over like right
now it's like it's like a Subway
sandwich you get a sandwich with two
bucks whatever thought what five bucks
is mm-hmm it's like grief and now reef
is eight on your dollars a pound up
sorry there ain't no more reef there
ain't no money and grow no because it's
everywhere yeah the abundance is high
it's it's it's but that's why the
importance is right so you're never
gonna get that only three network number
you're never gonna get no that's those
days it doesn't so what you have to do
is as an entertainer and this is why you
know it it takes a long time to get this
comfortable you have to figure out who
you are and do that and play to your
niche you're not playing to a third of
the country anymore you have to play to
the people that's which is what you've
done right you've found the people that
love you and I'll to you into what
you're and who you are and that's what
it is that's what entertainment is now
you're not ABC who's only three networks
so I guess forty million are gonna watch
because there's nothing else to watch
your niche finds you now a million and
if you don't know who you are now those
are the people who are really
floundering because there's no voice to
pull people in you have a very specific
voice it pulls people in and so when you
start to figure out who you are you
start to draw people in and that's what
the do that's why the last year has been
such a crazy growth for me not just
personally but professionally because I
finally started to I'm not draw I'm not
searching people out anymore
I'm just being Who I am and they're
finding me there's a difference there's
a difference the hardest thing to fathom
and I tell people this all the time on
Twitter and they must look at me like
I'm an [ __ ] when they ask for advice
it's the most basic thing that they tell
you you know it's most basic thing about
this thing is be yourself yeah that is
the hardest hardest thing yeah thing to
ever be in your life because you don't
accept you know hey they're not gonna
like me if I say I [ __ ] don't like
[ __ ] alligators somebody's gonna be
mad that somebody don't like you yeah
that's what somebody is always not gonna
like you even if you're perfect even if
you're [ __ ] perfect people don't
[ __ ] like you think I'm a reason not
to like
so you might as well be happy and float
your [ __ ] boat when you when they
came to me and said when when Jim masala
told me the first day I was here though
I should move to Las Vegas that I have
no business being here I'm a cabaret
comic do you know what I felt when like
[ __ ] death yeah that's like the club
owner to tell you that I didn't listen
and now he sees me he hugs me and I'm
his buddy
I have nothing against him I love ya at
least he was honest with me and then
blow smoke up my ass like most comedy
clubs did uh-huh but it was the truth
like it was the truth in it you have to
[ __ ] find your voice
believe in it stick to your guns and
tell everybody go [ __ ] yourself you know
why else look at we will walk oh look at
we the Walkman is opening up a Kid Rock
on the tour yeah he didn't give a [ __ ]
no you don't give a [ __ ] you put your
head down you move forward and you got a
fireman's hat on but two-by-fours are
happy by 6:00 14th of bouncing off your
head Joyce's are bouncing off yet yeah
that's just life and you know what you
hope for the best and you believe in
yourself and you always have the
distinction that I don't know I don't
know you're not going home beat up
that's the thing though like so what for
me one of the scariest parts of being
yourself is that look if you're not
being truly authentic to you and
somebody doesn't like you it doesn't
hurt as much
doesn't hurt because because you're like
well that's not me they're not they're
not saying no to me so when you put
yourself out there when you really put
your authentic you out there when
someone doesn't like that that's the
scary cart because then they're saying
you know oh that's me they don't like
but after a while you got to be like
that can't you can't change who you are
to try to placate other people that's
that's not a good way to go through life
you're gonna [ __ ] hate yourself I've
seen I've sat next to people restaurants
and listen to that conversation and I've
done everything I can not to hold myself
and go listen ball tease knock it off
should be so you're not that guy and
you're definitely not that guy yeah just
be yourself what's with the cap inside
and the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] are you
doing you just wait you know how long
it's gonna take you to realize you're
spinning
your [ __ ] wheels that's what it was
repent God that I had the Comedy Store
like that I could just go up there and
say whatever the [ __ ] I wanted to
because I encourage that that made me
going to clubs ago what are you talking
about
go [ __ ] yourself I remember one time I
went to Houston the other Club they paid
me 1,500 bucks for five shows is that
the one that that dude you said oh yes
with the daughter yeah yeah yeah yeah
and I went to that Club and the first
night he wasn't there the wife was there
she came in and she was like oh by the
way we weren't clean here and I go
uh-huh and she sat there and watched me
from 10 feet away and I had a bag of
dicks I mean I ain't such a bag of dicks
like I was just embarrassed and the next
thing I wanted and I go you know what
this [ __ ] club don't mean dick
compared to midsi sure I'm doing my
thing I ripped him apart ever went back
because right in the front row some
chick I could see her laughing and then
I can see her [ __ ] left thigh clothes
and then also I just seen him barf on
this thing that's how the show ended the
first thing barson on the stage and it
going everywhere all over the stage and
she's bar from the people around they
were getting up and running and she's
just sitting there with barf on his
shirt I'll never [ __ ] play here again
Joe this weekend hilarities is some dude
was fingering his girlfriend in the
second row for the almost the entire
Late Show Friday then you were watching
it the whole time and somebody was like
why didn't you say something I was like
it gave me something different to look
at you know I'm not used to seeing that
what am i they're not bothering anybody
they weren't being disruptive it wasn't
loud when about in Columbus a guy had a
seizure from edibles and Kate was
onstage and they had a cover with an
ambulance and this and they take the guy
Wayne the four guys like [ __ ] them we're
not normal
haha they didn't leave though they
stayed to watch me Kate huh it took 20
minutes for the ambulance to get into
the building
I go Keisha say what the cup club came
on like listen it's gonna take some time
you want to cancel the show they go no
let the ambulance got that cake go out
then do ain't hard and just bring me up
and it was perfect and afterward the
guys the guys came up with my [ __ ] cam
palms up eat that [ __ ] edible thank
you very much for coming on tonight I
always a pleasure thank you so much you
know I'm headed to Providence tomorrow
so I'll see you [ __ ] in
Providence and that's it that's not you
got a date you want to promote on here
yeah I'm in at the Addison improv this
weekend which is the 17th and 19th and
the weekend after that of a Memorial Day
I'm in San Francisco at Cobbs I'll be
there with my beautiful wife Bethany and
then one night only in Houston June 6 at
the improv and I'm given half of my
money to recovery Houston some more
people means more money for the charity
so come on out to that show thank you
brother you're a good man [ __ ]
Sycamore tavern tomorrow night 8 o'clock
by the time is coming that it was last
night well that was less but if your
give you're listening to this the day
comes out I'll be at the Ontario improv
with the smash brothers tonight all
right look at that time in front of this
master metallian all right don't forget
you're looking for a [ __ ] quality
Gifu G sports.com there's the way to go
then works their big day five nominate
five a couple more weeks I'll be in a
four they'll be ready to rock I got a
little gig you know saying all right I
love [ __ ] food you stuff they're the
only guy I wear whether it's a super 800
or the [ __ ] is Sakai or just a plain one
then my favorite Gaeta in lights you
could breathe I bought a gig one time
and we're like 82 [ __ ] pounds you
move around you're moving like a [ __ ]
body armor [ __ ] that [ __ ]
this is light breathable they got the
thing in them so they don't stink hey
listen I put my money on Fugees what are
you looking for shin straps boxing
gloves mats go to Fuji sports.com right
now press in charge BAM and get 10% off
number two you're looking for
supplements [ __ ] alpha brain gives
you a hundred percent money-back
guarantee even if you don't want who
does that when you're gonna [ __ ] them in
five guys if the burger sucks dick do
they give it back to you [ __ ] no [ __ ] no
[ __ ] though if you eat it and say I lied
you like it no no they don't we didn't
get what I'd you know heartburn oh I
thought you said Hodgkins Hodgkins
Anna got the shun tak Anna got the
[ __ ] shoot export Anna got the Alpha
brain and the [ __ ] protein I
get the 10% off on that the kettlebells
you're on your own so go to Anna calm
right now press in church BAM and get
10% off delivered right to your
[ __ ] house have a great weekend
uncle Joey loves you
Jersey get ready dirty Providence get
ready we're eating [ __ ] I'll
see you this weekend stay black Josh
wolf and my man [ __ ] the flying Jew
aka the Christ killer have a good
weekend